from 8 news now this is politics now
thank you very much for joining us here
on politics now i'm john langler the
meeting wednesday night stretched into
thursday morning and at the end clark
county school board members gave
superintendent dr jesus jarrah approval
to create a coronavirus vaccine mandate
policy now it's not in effect yet and
meanwhile unions are still waiting to
see exactly what the district does kate
houston breaks down the next
steps i spoke to two of the four unions
they're both eager to work through the
details of the plan with the school
district and avoid losing any employees
saying the district can't afford it it's
not ready to be mandated and it should
be a right we have to grow up and stop
throwing tantrums like five-year-olds
over a vaccine
opposing views over a resolution to
mandate the covid19 vaccine for school
district employees now the clark county
education association and clark county
association of school administrators and
professional technical employees are
working to represent both sides ccea
president marine isis wants to ensure
every staff member has a job since the
resolution passed she has heard from
concerned educators what are next steps
do i need to go ahead and quit now do i
apply for a job elsewhere you know we're
telling everyone to just you know hang
tight we're advocating for both sides
and we're seeing what we can come up
with after we meet with the district
nicest says one possible solution would
be for unvaccinated educators to do
distance education instead of being
inside the classroom another concern is
how the district will handle discipline
if an employee is not vaccinated jeff
horn with the ccasape says they'll be
specifically looking into this when
negotiating starts horn would not
support mandating termination if
employees are not vaccinated kate
houston 8 news now
both unions we discussed in that story
there expect the process to go fast at
ccsd they don't want it rushed though
now to the 2022 campaign trail wounded
former army captain sam brown made a
splash when he announced he was running
for senate here in nevada brown was
burned injured in afghanistan in 2008
after being hit by an improvised
explosive device you're looking at that
campaign video now
brown now lives in reno and he's running
as a republican for catherine
cortez-masto's senate seat
this week we sat down with brown to talk
about his candidacy and given the recent
end of the war in afghanistan a war
which injured brown we asked him about
his recent call for president biden and
other military leaders to resign
what has occurred
with
president biden's execution of this
withdrawal is
it has
damaged the trust of not only the
american people but the american soldier
and i've spent a lot of time over the
last couple of weeks talking to my
fellow soldiers folks that i served with
folks that i i didn't serve with but
served in other parts of afghanistan
folks who served in iraq
even some vietnam veterans and one of
the common themes that i'm hearing is
that
people feel that
they were used
by our government for a political agenda
do you believe that it was right to at
least withdraw even if the method was
wrong it was in your view wrong was the
general the the thought of actually
withdrawing the right move
yeah in in directionally i'm i was in
agreement with with a withdrawal
the execution of it was very terrible i
do also think that you know
the the circumstances in terms of the
way that the taliban was was moving and
the the decisions on leaving weapons and
equipment
you know could have changed how the
timeline of withdrawal which we never
should have been stating that to begin
with but yes i do think that americans
should have eventually withdrawn there's
recently been some movement on the issue
of daca that's been an ongoing
discussion in the courts and in the in
on capitol hill
back with the trump administration obama
and now into the bind administration
what
would you like to see moving forward
with daca and i guess more broadly
solving the immigration situation on the
border
yeah so
this is a prime example of a case where
politicians use a
real life human issue for
to be a a pawn on a campaign and
political cycle
daca recipients are
awarded that
deferment of action based off of hitting
certain criteria essentially
they they are they are good engaged
members of the community and
what i would like to see is
we move away from executive action where
we just leave it to whoever happens to
sit in the white house to make a lot of
those decisions congress needs to
address this issue without
waiving this threat of deporting people
who've been a good member of society
every two years
and congress needs to address this
provide long-term
deferment for those people who
continue to be a good member of society
and address that issue in conjunction
with making sure that we secure the
border that has to be an active part of
that there's adam laxalt running as well
for this seat you mentioned a little bit
about the the political
establishment the political class
i guess do you consider mr laxalt as
being part of that and how do you
differentiate yourself from
from from adam
you know adam's experience kind of
speaks for itself
he's been a part of you know running
four campaigns and involved in nevada
politics since
he moved here shortly after 2013
and
you know his record stands for itself
and so i i differentiate myself in in
terms of
i i have not
have not entered this race as someone
who
is is aspiring to be a career politician
or has a long history of working in
politics or around politics and so i
bring a perspective
of um living in a in a world where you
know i can relate to my neighbors my
kids go go to the same schools as my as
my neighbors and you know i have i've
had real jobs and i continue to work
real jobs and and that's what nevadans
need is someone who understands our our
issues
we also asked brown about his views on
economic policy and infrastructure you
can see the full interview at
8newsnow.com we also have interviews
with the other republicans who have
announced they are running for senate
one of those candidates as we mentioned
in that interview is former state
attorney general adam laxalt this week
laxalt named his campaign co-chairs and
there are nearly three dozen of them
they include former governor bob list
city of las vegas mayor pro-tem stavros
anthony and former clark county
commissioner bruce woodbury laxalt's one
of several republicans trying to unseat
democratic senator cortez masto in 2022
culinary union leaders and democrats in
the latino community here in the valley
are attacking laxalt's stance on the
infrastructure bill which is working its
way through congress right now
they say a vote for him is a vote for
former president donald trump mr trump
has endorsed laxalt who is against the
bipartisan infrastructure plan that's
expected to bring thousands of new jobs
to nevada
we know he doesn't care about nevada he
doesn't care about anything
the only thing he cares is about to
please donald trump out the gate laxalt
would attack something that's going to
bring billions of dollars to this state
that's going to go to the very kids
we've been working with
in response mr laxalt's campaign said
quote trump mr trump gained latino
support by focusing on the needs of the
american working family many of which
are proud hard-working latinos and
laxalt was there all along unquote
caesar's palace says it will not host a
scheduled conference linked to the q
anon conspiracy theory the patriot
double down event was scheduled for late
october and among those listed as
speakers was republican candidates for
secretary of state jim marchand
q anon is that far-right conspiracy
group which believes former president
trump will expose a group of satan
worshiping pedophile cannibals and
declare martial law
it is unclear where the event will be
held now
nevada democrats are speaking out
against a restrictive texas abortion law
it went into effect on thursday after
the u.s supreme court declined an
emergency appeal to stop it justices
still need to rule though on the
legality of the law what texas lawmakers
passed prohibits nearly all abortions
once a fetal heartbeat can be detected
usually about six weeks
critics say that's before many women
know that no they're pregnant instead of
relying on government officials to
enforce the law what texas past empowers
anyone in the united states to sue texas
abortion providers and anyone who
assists with an abortion
opponents say that could even include
for example a friend who drives a woman
to her abortion appointment or a clergy
member who offers advice
the law provides at least a ten thousand
dollar reward for anyone who files a
lawsuit and wins
it makes no exception for cases of rape
or incest only for medical emergencies
nevada's congressional democrats all had
very strong criticism for that texas
bill except more legal challenges moving
forward
in nevada access to abortion is
guaranteed in the state constitution up
to 24 weeks of pregnancy that wasn't a
ballot initiative passed back in 1990 a
law similar to what was passed in texas
could never really move forward here
even if roe versus way that case was
overturned it would take in nevada a
constitutional amendment and a general
election vote to remove it welcome back
to politics now
[Music]
local attorney seagal chatta has sued
governor steve sisalik and the state of
nevada several times the motive covid
mandates she won litigation over
capacity limits in churches already a
case is ongoing that deals with the
indoor mask mandate chattah now is
running as a republican for attorney
general against democratic incumbent
aaron ford
in several
lawsuits other litigation
with regards to those issues
what is it about the regulations that
were put in place
the mandates that you find
unconstitutional
well one of the things that we have to
look at is that there was a lot of
arbitrariness
in these
decisions
we saw that they were not based on
science for example you could open up a
casino and you can have people gaming
but you can go to a place of worship
and
those things just simply don't make
sense
you can have people in large gatherings
in restaurants
but you couldn't go to again you know
certain uh
certain restaurants that had bars there
were all these arbitrary rules that none
of them made sense with the science do
you believe the 2020 election was stolen
i don't think that the 2020 election was
stolen you don't think that the claims
of uh fraudulent ballots or any those
are value think that uh the president
for example won fair and square look
here's here's your idea only because you
brought up election integrity right the
the reality of it is
i'm a lawyer unless i see proof
it doesn't exist that's how i've
litigated my cases that's how i've
defended my cases okay so unless i see
concrete proof that there was a steel
i don't believe it
okay now that doesn't say that doesn't
mean that there was
not issues with voter fraud yes we have
evidence of voter fraud but to take that
and to make that leap from certain voter
fraud to a stolen election
i'm a very pragmatic attorney i need to
see the proof whether the attorney
general's office should do the pattern
and practice investigations into use of
force uh as attorney general if you're
elected would you follow through with
that or what do you think is the best
way for police to be investigated you
know i want to tell you that after 2014
and i want to
commend
the sheriff in this
joe lombardo has done an incredible job
with the i think
after 2014 what we saw is the
recalibration
of lvmpd and the police department so to
unilaterally decide that our police
department needs to be tweaked i don't
agree with that i think again the
sheriff has done an outstanding job
since 2014. the opioid lawsuits the
issue of painkillers and the state of
nevada was not involved in a broader
lawsuit do you believe that the state
should have been involved in that or do
you
think the best way to go about it to try
and get some
penalty back was for nevada to go solo
i don't agree with the ag's decision to
opt out of the 26 billion dollar
settlement the global settlement
and the reason why i don't agree with
that is because again
sometimes a bird in the hand is better
than two in the sky
i think that right now
families in nevada are entitled to
recovery i think right now we need
recovery in the state of nevada
for institutions that help opioid
addiction i i don't necessarily agree
that holding out for either a better set
a better settlement down the road or
holding out for a higher jury verdict is
the right thing to do when you're
compromising people's ability to obtain
recovery now
chatta says the first thing she would
bring to the attorney general's office
if she's elected is she says
transparency she explores that more and
we have a lot more of a discussion with
her the full interview is at eight
newsnow dot com we did ask the attorney
general mr ford to do an interview as
well at this time he said he has no
availability
[Music]
tens of thousands of afghans evacuated
in the final days of the war in
afghanistan well they're now here in the
u.s and there are talks in congress
about trying to raise the refugee cap
meanwhile the bide administration says
about 100 americans are still in
afghanistan officials are trying to work
to get them out for now those afghans
are being brought to the u.s
as of this morning there are
approximately twenty thousand afghans
who arrived at eight different military
bases in the continental united states
joining us now from our washington dc
bureau alex general limon to talk about
this issue alex let's get into it some
groups some lawmakers are pushing for
the biden administration to increase
that refugee camp cap to let more come
into the united states that's an ongoing
discussion where do things stand right
now
well first off the biden administration
had already increased the refugee cap
this year significantly to more than
000 refugees and had already announced
plans for the refugee camp to increase
to about 125 000 for the next fiscal
year which actually begins next month on
october 1st but humanitarian agencies
around the world and a group of
progressive democrats like you said are
pushing for the administration and the
president to raise the refugee cap even
further they would like to see the
number of 200 000 refugees for the year
citing of course the end of the war in
afghanistan saying there are just so
many translators and others who helped
the united states but then also their
family members you know who may be at
risk or in danger because of the taliban
threatening their lives for helping the
u.s and that's not the only issue these
progressive democrats and others say
there are other crises happening around
the world like in haiti for example and
they say that's why there is this need
however at this point we have not heard
uh anything from the biden
administration as far as you know
agreeing to raise the cap so as far as
we know for next year that will still be
at 125 000 refugees
meanwhile we have talked to some
republicans on capitol hill
who say that they are actually opposed
to raising the refugee cap i spoke to
texas congressman jody arrington for
example and he cited being against that
idea because he says there's also
already so many asylum seekers that are
arriving to our southern border now
those are different numbers those
numbers don't contribute toward the
refugee camp but he says in total
there's already too much immigration
happening
there's some concern about the vetting
process with so many people from
afghanistan coming here to the united
states
what is the vetting process now to make
sure that the people who are getting
here to our shores
are supposed to be here
yeah i think part of the concern is that
we've heard such large numbers tens of
thousands of people arriving to the
united states from afghanistan in such a
short and quick amount of time but
press secretary jensachi this week said
that there is absolutely no one who is
coming to the united states uh no afghan
person who has not already been
thoroughly vetted and background checked
before heading to the u.s and that's
actually something that we heard from
pentagon officials as well even much
earlier in the process when they were
still actively evacuating people out of
afghanistan pentagon officials you know
stressed that anyone who got onto a
plane headed to the united states either
from afghanistan or from a third country
was thoroughly vetted and background
checked before they even stepped foot on
a plane and so we do know that the white
house and biden administration is
working with states around the country
and governors and other officials to
make sure that everyone understands that
and that they kind of address those
concerns before refugees head to those
states around the country
it is a mammoth task alex simone joining
us from washington thank you very much
a school board in virginia was about
three hours into its meeting recently
when a bart simpson lined up the public
comment agenda with some fake names
wayne kerr
eileen dover
yes we can't play most of those fake
names here on television but the board
read about half dozen of them this was
video taken by a local newspaper there
in virginia and it turned out only one
person actually addressed the board
all right so here's a look at what to
watch this week in politics and chiefly
it is unemployment two federal programs
providing unemployment have ended here
in nevada and nationwide combined here
in nevada they had about 116 000 claims
for both programs here in nevada in the
last week before they ended so we're
going to look into what they may do to
the job market here in las vegas
also next week marks 20 years since this
attacks on september 11. so we have
several special stories lined up for you
next week about the uh tragedy covering
it we'll have the remembrances as well
all week long on eight news now and of
course here on politics now as well we
thank you so much for joining us here on
politics now all the latest political
news at eight newsnow dot com have a
good week we'll see you next week